على الجانب الروسي اعلن حاكم مدينه سيف
سوبر في شبه جزيره القرمخائيل راسو جاييف
ان منظومات الدفاع الجوي اسقطت طائره
مسيره فوق البحر الاسود بالقرب من البدينه
واضاف المسؤول الروسيه الى طائره بدون
طيار اسقطت فوق خليجي سيباستيكول وان جميع
الخدمات في المدينه تعمل كالمعتاد على احد
تعبيره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها احببته هجوما
للجيش الاوكراني على المواقع الثابته
لمقاتلها دون تحديد مكانها
ان الدبابات الروسيه دمرت مواقع اوكرانيه
مفيده باستسام عدد من المقاتلين الاوكراني
متابعه تطورات مع مراسلنا من خرصون تامر
اسم ماضي ومن برغامي ابدا معك امين من حيث
كنا نتحدث الان اسقاط هذه المسيره فيفا
سبورت وما يجري الحديث عنه ايضا بخصوص تلك
المناورات الروسيه البيلاروسيه
[تصفيق]
الحوادث في الحقيقه اصبحت شبه او تجري على
الاقل بشكل اسبوعي الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه كما تعلن السلطات هناك في شبه
جزيره القرم تتصدى لمحاولات هجوم على
مواقع لا تذكره همم في غالب الاحيان وتؤكد
طبعا السلطات عبر البياناتها الرسميه
لدرجه الاولى على انها تحبط كل تلك
الهجمات اليوم كما ذكرت مريم انطلقت همم
التدريبات الجويه التكتيكيه بين الجيشين
الروسي والبيلا روسي في بيلاروسيا وزاره
الدفاع في مينسك اعلنت همم امس وصوله عدد
من القوات التابعه للقوات الجويه
والفضائيه الروسيه التي سترك في هذه
المناورات التي ستستمر في مختلف ميادين
التدريب في اوكران في بيلاروسيا عفوا
اضافه الى المطارات العسكريه همم على مدى
اسبوعين اي الى الاول من شهر فبراير
المقبل الوزاره ايضا تحدثت عن الاهداف
التي
ستسعى القوات المشاركه في هذه المناورات
تحقيقها تتعلق في اجراء دوريات جويه
مشتركه على طول حدود البلاد كما قالت
اضافه الى القيام بعمليات مناوره وايصال
مؤن واجلاء جرحى وتعزيز اا ال- العمل
القتالي والتواصل بين مختلف وحدات القوات
الجويه سواء من الروسيه او البلار روسيه
المشاركه في هذه القوات التي تدخل في اطار
ما يعرف بقوات الدفاع الاقليمي المشتركه
التي انشئت بين ميسكو موسكو في شهر اكتوبر
الماضي ميدانيا اليوم سلطات الموليه
لروسيا في دنياك قالت ان اربعه مدنيين على
الاقل اص وفي قصف اوكرانيا على حي
كالينزكي وسط مدينه دونياس بعد الوسائل
الاعلام الموليه لروسيا في دونياس كالان
تتحدث عن سقوط قتيلين
وثلاثه جرحه من المصادر الرسميه لا زالت
لم تؤكد هذا الرقم واا تحدثت ايضا السلطات
هناك عن ان قواتها ما زلت تستهدف مواقع
الجيش الاوكراني في بلدات محيط مدينه
دونيسك بعد ان كانت المدينه النسبيا شهدت
هدوءا خلال الايام الاخيره لكن على ما
يبدو ان القصف اشتد امس اليوم على وسط هذه
المدينه بحسب طبعا السلطات المواليه
لروسيا هناك الموقع عباره العسكري المتخصص
اليوم تحدث عن ان قوه فاجنر ما زالت تشن
هجماتها من مختلفه المحاور على مدينه
محمود همم تحدثت عن سيطره قوه فاجنر على
مواقع اوكرانيه جديده في بلده كلي شيفكي
التي تقع الى الجنوب من مدينه بخموت اللي
كتب عن في هجوم من محاور ثلاثه همم
متزامنه هذه الهجمات على مدينه بخمس في
سوليدار ما زالت المصادر الروسيه سواء من
العسكريه او اا العسكريه الميدانيه
الماليه لها في اقليم دون باست تؤكد على
ان المدينه باتت بشكل كامل تحت السيطره
وموقع ريبارا اليوم ايضا اكد على ان
القوات الروسيه ام سيطرت على منجم الملح
رقم سبعه في المنطقه همم الصناعيه الغربيه
من مدينه سوليدارو بانها وسعت هجماتها في
تلك المنطقه واستدل على صحه تلك المعلومات
بما كانت قيادات عسكريه ميدانيه اوكرانيا
امس قد تحدثت عنه حينما قالت بانها فقدت
السيطره على تلك المنطقه المواجهه وخط
الجبهه الرئيسي الان في مدينه سوليدار بات
فعليا خارج حدود المدينه